bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur sociaux logos dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui je voulais revenir sur un
cliché que je trouve assez malheureux
concernant les universitaires c'est
cette idée que les chercheurs et
chercheuses sont coupés du monde dans un
entre soi que leur recherche peut être
ne servent à rien en quelque sort
puisque c'est seulement de la critique
pour la critique niveau intellectuel et
cetera c'est un cliché qui comme tous
les clichés à une part de vérité mais
c'est un préjugé que je trouve assez
triste puisque en fait les
universitaires ont beaucoup à nous
apprendre
dans mon cas en sciences sociales
notamment aux sociologies c'est quand
même la porte d'entrée vers une
meilleure compréhension du monde
je trouve ça vraiment injuste de juger
les universitaires pour un espèce
d'entre eux soit qu'ils entretiendraient
et du fai duquel il serait totalement
inutile à la société et donc pour venir
à contrebalancer un petit peu cette idée
reçue j'ai décidé de vous présenter
trois chercheuses qui ont changé ma vie
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas je suis
doctorante en sociologie et je suis
spécialisé en études de genre donc
forcément les trois chercheuses que je
vais vous présenter ces des chercheuses
qui se définissent eux mêmes comme des
chercheuses féministe mon premier grand
choc universitaire je m'en souviens
comme si c'était hier c'était en 2015 et
c'était la lecture des textes de vent
d'anarchie va maintenant lâché valls et
une physicienne indienne dont calais
doctoresse en physique quantique pas de
la sociologie a priori mais elle s'est
beaucoup intéressé en fait à la physique
quantique concernant les semences donc
c'est à dire masque est à la base de
notre alimentation tout simplement
et la particularité de bandanas chivas
et qu'en plus d'être une
universitaire elle s'est investie dans
des mouvements militants de préservation
des semences traditionnelles en inde en
militant notamment contre deux grands
groupes agro industriel qui venaient à
menacer les écosystèmes et vandana shiva
est surtout connue pour avoir été une
des premières théoricienne de son appel
l'écho féminisme avec une sociologue
allemande maria miss elles ont écrit un
livre qui s'appelle l'écoféminisme qui
m'a énormément marqué ça a été tout
simplement ma première grande claque
théorique c'était bien avant que je le
retrouve plongée dans les études de
genre et j'étais en fait dans un cours
d'économie du développement
quand j'étais en erasmus est tout
simplement une révélation
en fait dans lego féminisme mariam sy se
vendre à shiva montre que les femmes et
la nature sont opprimés et exploités par
le cen capitaliste de la même manière
selon en fait les mêmes mécanismes
elle montre que l'appropriation non
rémunéré du corps des femmes en tant que
moyen reproductif mais également en tant
que machine à force de travail
fonctionnent selon le même mécanisme que
l'appropriation des ressources
naturelles dans le cas où les humains ne
paye pas le prix écologique des
ressources qu'ils emploient et donc la
conclusion d'un ouvrage extrêmement
détaillées qui est donc l'ouvragé du
sociologue mais aussi d'une physicienne
c'est de me dire que la population des
femmes et des ressources naturelles
fonctionne selon les mêmes mécanismes et
ça dans ma compréhension du capitalisme
et de la manière dont le système
capitaliste fonctionne ça a été tout
simplement une révélation
puisqu'en parce qu'elle me dit c'est que
deux faits la sortie du système
capitaliste ne pourra se faire que par
une révolution à la fois féministe et
écologiste
en fait prendre conscience que la
manière dont on exploite les femmes
c'est la même manière que le système à
d'exploiter la nature ça a été
on va dire la première prise de
conscience d'une imbrication des
rapports de domination et des rapports
de pouvoir au sein d'un même système et
c
quelque chose qui est assez fondamentale
en sociologie de comprendre les
différents rapports de pouvoir qui
régissent la société qui opposent des
groupes antagonistes et c est donc à
l'époque j'étais étudiante en sciences
politiques mais j'ai tout simplement
fait mes premiers pas dans la sociologie
avec vandana shiva alors la seconde à
personne que je souhaite vous présenter
aujourd'hui s'appelle nicole claude
mathieu et une anthropologue française
qui était spécialiste des études de
genre donc qui est vraiment une
référence dans son domaine d'étude et
vous la connaissez peut-être sans la
connaître
du fait de grands féministe cd n'est pas
consentir et oui car céder n'est pas
consentir c'est en fait le titre de l'un
de ses articles tout simplement qui est
devenu par la suite un slogan très
fréquent dans les manifestations
féministes et donc ce n'est pas consenti
hier comme tous ces articles majeurs
sont rassemblées dans un ouvrage qui
s'intitule l'anatomie politique et qui a
été la grande révélation que j'arrivais
en master 2 de sociologie en études de
genre alors la première chose qui m'a
marqué avec nicole mathieu c'est tout
simplement la manière dont elles
démontrent que les sciences sociales et
notamment l'anthropologie l'ethnographie
son genre et elle a en fait démontré
scientifiquement point par point qu'il
existe un biais dans les études de
sciences sociales notamment
d'anthropologie l'ethnographie qui est
le biais androcentrique l'androcentrisme
c'est le fait de diffuser des études qui
sont écrites par des hommes qui ne sont
pas sortis du prisme masculin et qui du
coup ont une analyse biaisée de certains
phénomènes qu'ils rapportent
et au delà du billet c'est aussi sa
manière de montrer que alors soit il ya
une mauvaise compréhension de phénomènes
sociaux observés dans d'autres peuples
soit qu'il y avait même un oubli en fait
d' analyses de certains phénomènes parce
que relevant des problématiques de
femmes et qui du coup les hommes
scientifique n'est pas sensible sur le
moment de nouveaux nicole que mathieu
trouve scientifiquement qu'il ya un
regard masculin qui a pu être posée sur
des événements et que au nom de la
science on a pris comme universelles
quelque chose qui ne voyaient pas toute
la réalité
et notamment en ne prenant pas en compte
les dynamiques de genre que recouvre
certains événements et certains
phénomènes sociaux je pense ici
notamment à lévis treuz qui est bien sûr
et en anthropologue majeur qui a marqué
la discipline mais qui pour autant n'a
pas su toujours expliquer des phénomènes
sociaux parce que il avait en lui ce
biais andrew centriste qui est de ne pas
sortir de son regard bascule ce qui m'a
surtout marqué avec cet article denis
coq le mathieu en fait c'est le fait que
soit démontrée scientifiquement
parce que quand on fait ce genre de
critique quand on les formules on est
assez vite taxé de féministes militantes
machin est en fait nicole claude mathieu
avec d'autres femmes de sa génération
elles ont tout simplement
institutionnaliser les études féministes
en france et en montrant que ça une
rigueur tout à fait scientifique et que
les féministes peuvent lui permettre de
voir des choses qui n'ont pas été
montrés jusqu'à présent est de mieux
comprendre la société dans laquelle nous
vivons
la troisième personne que je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui c'est une
chercheuse du nom de paola tabet paola
tabet c'est une anthropologue italienne
qui est devenu incontournable
à partir du moment où je me suis penché
sur la question du travail agricole et
notamment des femmes dans le travail
agricole
tout simplement parce que une grande
partie de son travail se penche sur les
questions de la technique de
l'utilisation du corps et des outils
dans le travail alors son oeuvre majeure
qui est la construction sociale de
l'inégalité des sexes comporte deux
parties qui sont tous les deux est
extrêmement riche d'enseignements la
première partie de cet ouvrage s'appelle
les mains les outils les armes et
revient sur plusieurs points concernant
l'utilisation d'outils ou de technique
en fait par la tablette a théorisé
l'exclusion systématique des femmes de
l'utilisation des outils de production
elle a théorisé le fait que les femmes
sont systématiquement ramené à
l'utilisation de leur corps en tant que
machine à force de travail et n'ont pas
accès aux mêmes techniques que les
hommes il ya toute une réflexion sur le
fait que les femmes sont forcés de
rester dans une utilisation
naturel de leur corps quand les hommes
se voient plus facilement attribuer des
outils qui augmentent leurs possibilités
et leurs forces sur nature est en fait
de la en montrant que les femmes sont
exclues d'utilisation des outils
techniques elles montrent qu'elles sont
réduites à leur état de nature et donc
elle ne peut pas s'en affranchir ça se
rapproche aussi de thèse en fait de
simone de beauvoir qui me dit que pour
s'affranchir il faut pouvoir maîtriser
l'état de nature
la seconde partie de l'ouvragé de paola
tabet s'intitule fertilité naturelle
reproduction forcé bien que le titre est
extrêmement évocateur une des grande
partie des études sur le genre repose
sur l'analyse de ce qu'on appelle le
travail reproductif
c'est un travail qui à l'échelle
mondiale est presque de tout temps et
effectuer gratuitement pour les femmes
c'est non seulement le fait d'enfants
thé mais également d' éduquer des
enfants et de participer de manière plus
générale au travail du caire c'est à
dire au travail du soin envers à la fois
les enfants et les personnes âgées
le travail de reproduction il est
essentiel au système dans lequel on dit
et pourtant les femmes ne sont pas
rémunérés pour effectuer ce travail et
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
quelque chose que pour lui la [ __ ]
m'a appris tout simplement fait parole
est à m un statut que le système
capitaliste s'effondrerait en l'absence
de travail de reproduction sociale menée
par les femmes est la plus grande partie
de son argumentaire c'est de démontrer
que ce travail qui est effectué
gratuitement par les femmes les
légitimes et il est justifié par l'idée
que les femmes seraient naturellement
plus apte à le faire du fait de leur
fertilité naturelle
c'est comme ça notamment que les femmes
stériles ont longtemps été perçu par
raison comme des sorcières ou que les
femmes qui refusera des enfants sont
marginalisés dans la société et cetera
xc
voilà je vous en dit pas plus sur ses
trois universitaires j'espère que ça
vous aura en fait donne envie de les
découvrir tout simplement j'ai pas
forcément envie ici de vous faire des
grands résumé ou des fiches de lecture
ou alors ce sera peut-être pour une
prochaine fois qui sait pour le moment
j'espère juste que ça vous a permis
d'entendre un petit peu voilà les thèses
qui sont là soutenu par des
universitaires féministes devant
ray que oui ça sert à quelque chose
puisque ça sert à comprendre le monde
dans lequel on vit
savoir c'est pouvoir donc le travail de
ces universitaires il peut tout
simplement changer des vies et changer
même le monde
voilà ça se voit la petite touche
d'utopie j'espère que cette vidéo vous
aura intéressé et je reviendrai pourquoi
pas peut-être avec d'autres
universitaires et celui d'autres sphères
en attendant je vous propose de vous
abonner à ma chaîne youtube et vous
pouvez me retrouver également sur
instagram le lien est dans la barre
d'infos et puis je vous dis surtout à
très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo sur
ces logos
[Musique]